so if we take a step to uh our previous
discussion of going from
zero to hero
so going from the the early days through
the teenage years to winning
an olympic medal so we mentioned
a lot of training the dedication of the
training
the competing what other elements are
there the mental side is a visualization
believing that you could
perform at that level uh so what else
can you say about it i think that comes
at the highest level the visualization
the success that comes at the highest
level i think in the teen years um
there's the experience just plays a huge
role in getting to
train with other people like as
americans we have to go train in europe
we have to feel the european style of
judo we have to understand that
physicality they they grip very
differently they put you in very
unorthodox
positions and if you when if you don't
know how to deal with that you get
thrown before you even have a chance to
try your own throws you know so it takes
a lot of
it takes a lot of that experience and
understanding what's going on
and then you also need to get that
physicality you need to be physically
strong and and hard i would say by doing
all those rounds with the europeans and
at the same time you need to go to asia
and you need to train in in japan
because you need to feel that
free-flowing
judo for your technical the technical
side and i think that's
one of the things that i was able to
benefit from my dad was a coach who said
listen i've taken you as far as i can
take you
i want you to go to the next level i
want you know he sent me to to england
with neil adams who was an olympic
silver medalist and was a world champion
had a great ground game and was good at
gripping and actually did taotoshi which
is the throw i did so but i said i want
to go learn from neil and i ended up
going to
to england probably eight to ten times
in my career and spending a good amount
of time there training at the nail adams
academy
um he's now the voice of judo neil adams
what do you make of that guy just a
brief pause he's like the
like uh morgan freeman is the voice of
like march of the penguins and any other
nature documentary and neil adams is uh
there's very few sports that have a neil
adams i would say because
he's legitimately maybe like joe rogan
is that from mixed martial arts it's
just like an exceptionally
recognizable voice he's really
knowledgeable also the passion is
conveyed so well like many times i'll
watch just because he's talking right so
who is he since he gotten the chance to
train with him to learn from him who's
neil adams he's a great friend of mine
he is he's a mentor
like i said i lived and trained at the
neil adams club in coventry england
since i was like 16 years old i went and
visited him for the first time he's the
one who originally taught me how to do
juju gatami and the way that i do
jujigatami
um i trained with him he was just
retired he was in his early 30s when i
first went out there and you know so i
trained with him many times and
over the years he's he was a mentor
um great person you know cares that
cares about people cares about you know
the sport of judo um
had a good little club that was a
fitness club and you know had it was it
was judo it was fitness it it you know
used to go there i'd show up at that
place at like seven in the morning and
the first thing we would do is we'd go
for a run and we'd either be running
mountains or we'd be doing a five mile
run or we'd be doing something at the
park we were doing sprints and buddy
carries and all this stuff and then at 9
00 a.m we'd have a technical session
with neil adams where he would you know
for an hour and a half we would drill
techniques and learn positions and it
was no randori it was that sequential
drilling that we talked about before
right where you're reinforcing your your
two or three attacks to set up your main
attack or if you're on the ground you're
going through repetitions of certain
movements
um
and then i'd spend all afternoon at the
club have lunch i'd go do my weight
training in the afternoon at that at
that place and then in the evening we
would either do randori training at the
nail adams club or we would all get in a
car and we'd drive to another another
location
you know and we'd go train at another
club that might be an hour away and
there'd be you know 50 bodies there to
train with and each night we'd go to a
different dojo and so it would be all
day at the club and i'd do that for like
three weeks straight you know all we did
was try do you know how he became the
voice of judo do you have an
understanding
of what he's thinking is around like how
much he dedicates to himself
to just uh commentating on you i imagine
the amount of research
required but also just like
psychologically just the excitement he
has in his voice
it it takes work to do that do you have
an understanding of like what his vision
is with that he's always been a very
charismatic uh animated person neil you
know very passionate and loud and you
know funny and the brits are very funny
to begin with so he's he's you know very
charismatic but um
i think after coaching he tried coaching
he coached the country of wales for a
while he tried coaching stints in other
countries he didn't he didn't have a lot
of success on the coaching side
um developing an olympic champion i know
that some that was a goal of his that he
he was a world champion i think it was
1981 he won two silver medals in the
olympic games um himself
he went on to coach for a while and had
some political issues with the the
country of of england for a while and
then left england and went to wales and
i think he had a coaching somewhere else
as well
didn't have a lot of success coaching in
the sport with athletes not at the
highest level had a great national team
and things like that he was really good
at
at teaching his technique to others
because he helped me a lot
but running a program i think was
difficult for him you know the boy's not
listening and not having that same kind
of passion and intensity that he and
that's why i bonded well with him
because i was all in right i went there
and whatever he said i did i didn't care
how hard i didn't care how long i just
wanted to get as good as i could and so
that's why he was a good mentor for me
but now in terms of a um a commentator
he he's very cerebral he just he he
loves judo he he look researches it
non-stop
um he's got that great voice and he
knows how to bring bring life to the
you know to the game and that's what
he's done and now this is who he is
right he he does judo full time this is
his job
you